Speaker 1: Kyle Rittenhouse is doing
his rounds in conservative circles.
And the latest on him is that there's actually
a dispute between him and Texas A&M University
over whether he's going to be going to
school there in the fall and taking classes.
Kyle said recently on the Charlie Kirk show
that he was going to be going to the university.
The university, however, says otherwise. They
say that he has not been admitted and won't
be taking classes there. How on earth did
this happen? Let's first go to the clip of
Kyle explaining to Charlie Kirk that
he is going to become an Aggie and
putting on the Texas A&M cap to celebrate.
Speaker 5: He's ready to make. This is like
he's ready to make it. Wow, everybody. It's a
big deal right here on the Charlie Kirk Show,
Kyle Rittenhouse is announcing that he's an Aggie.
Speaker 6: So I'm going to be going there and it's
going to be awesome. Beautiful
campus, amazing people, amazing food.
We went to Dixie to check in there. Best burgers.
Speaker 5: I've ever. That's why he's going.
Speaker 6: Texas chicken.
Speaker 5: Everybody. Now, do you know what they
say at A&M? They say gig him, gig them. And you
know how they say hello. They say howdy. Howdy. So
there you go. And so you're going to you're going
to be are you going to join the corps cadets?
Speaker 6: I haven't decided yet. I may.
Speaker 1: Well, that was all very interesting.
But the university disputes Kyle's claim on this.
Kelly Brown, who's the spokesperson for Texas A&M,
said, quote, He has not been admitted as a student
this summer or fall. Now, typically, when you have
one person claiming one thing and another person
claiming another, you have to sort of weigh the
arguments to determine who's in the right and
who's in the wrong or maybe who's telling the
truth and who's not telling the truth. With the
case like this, though, it's pretty clear that
whatever Texas A&M says goes like they're going to
be the correct ones in all this because it's up to
them. Right, that they don't want to allow him as
a student at the school, then he's not going to be
going to that school. And that's just kind of the
end of that. Like I could say that I'm going to
Harvard or Yale or wherever to take classes, but
if those schools don't actually admit me, then I'm
not going to be going to those universities. But
with regard to this Texas A&M situation, I just
wonder exactly how it happened. Right. Like. Was
he sent a denial letter, but he thought it was
an acceptance letter. Was he initially accepted?
And then they decided to rescind the acceptance.
Was there just some incredible misunderstanding?
What exactly happened? I mean, maybe there was
a planned charade with all this where he wanted
to force the university's hand into allowing him
to go to the school. And maybe he wanted to make
some broader point to a right wing audience about
liberal indoctrination and cancel culture at
college campuses. I'm just not exactly sure. Funny
enough, Kyle has been working on a grift he calls
the Media Accountability Project or Team Map.
I don't know why they didn't just go with MAP for
the acronym. They went with Team App, but team app
has the purpose of suing people for defamation
and going after the corporate press because
Kyle felt like he was defamed during his murder
trial. And so he wants to get revenge against
a bunch of people. But it's like one of those
things where, Kyle, if you're going to be doing
this, you're going to be working for team app.
You can't be going on Charlie Kirk's show and
saying things that aren't true because maybe the
organization is going to have to go after you.
Before this, Kyle was taking classes at ASU,
Arizona State University, and he dropped the
classes to focus on the homicide trial. He wanted
to resume classes there after the trial ended,
but a bunch of students had an uproar and
the university decided to cut ties with them.
You said in a follow up tweet that actually he's
going to be going to Blinn College, a community
school out in Texas, tweeting, Unfortunately, the
end of my high school career was robbed from me.
I didn't have the time other students
get to properly prepare for the future.
I look forward to attending Blinn College District
this year, a feeder school for Texas A&M. I'm
excited to join Texas A&M in 2023, so apparently
he's going to blend college, although how can we
know for sure? Because he wasn't exactly accurate
when it came to the Texas A&M situation. So
maybe in a week or two we'll find out that he
actually wasn't admitted there. And wouldn't
that be something? And you have to wonder also
if this is going to cause a wave of students to
leave Blinn College to transfer somewhere else
because they just don't want to associate with
Kyle Rittenhouse. And I feel mixed feelings about
that sort of thing, because on the one hand, those
students have every right to transfer if they just
don't want to associate themselves with Kyle. On
the other hand, Rittenhouse was put through the
criminal justice system, and he was found not
guilty by a jury of his peers. And so there's this
idea that he should be allowed to rejoin society,
and that can include seeking higher levels of
education and trying to better himself and all
these different things. So I do think he should
be able to go to college somewhere. But when when
you're talking about some specific college that
has to let him in or doesn't have to let him in,
that's where it gets tricky because the colleges
have every right to make their own decisions.
The students who go to those schools, they have
every right to make those decisions. So that's
the latest on Kyle Rittenhouse apparently
becoming a college student in the fall.